my mom threatened me with the Cleveland
once when I was a kid my mom was like I
had the body Slammer dude my body's not
on the couch to have a soft Landing when
I was like a freshman or sophomore she
lost it yeah she lost it and I was like
man this crazy
she's swinging at me I picked I body
slammed her and then I went out with the
homies I went out with the homies
dude front line in her bathrobe like
this
my home's dropping me off dude your
mom's tripping I'm like I know she's
like this every day
she must have lost her mind with you as
a son that's probably buried a lot of
memories just like how I buried a lot of
my own memories when I bring it up she
was like cutting uh with The Cutting
Board I'm like whoa whoa whoa and my mom
starts laughing yeah